there was a spanish athlete yvonne
fernandez anaya who was competing in a
cross-country race and he was running in
second place he was behind the leader
abell mutai
and
as they entered the final straight he
saw the kenyan runner basically just
pull up and stop running 10 meters
before the finish line as he was coming
up he could have passed him he realized
there was no injury just
the first place guy mutai
just didn't realize where the finish
line was it's all you know just got made
a mistake
and he basically could have easily
passed him the guy was not even paying
attention was looking down and he told
him the finish line is over there you
should cross and people afterwards said
you know you could have won and that you
would have really won in other words he
didn't finish the race it wouldn't have
been like you knocked him down or
something he just didn't complete the
race and he said you know i just didn't
deserve to win it i did what i had to do
he was the rightful winner i could not
have closed the gap he created if he
hadn't just made a mistake about the
finish line what do you think is this
unusual would you have done the same
thing